بث التلفزيون الحكومي في روسيا في وقت سابق اليوم
صورًا لما يقولون
إنها مداهمة للشرطة مثل وجود أي
احتياطات للمنزل في سان بطرسبرج ،
واحد منهم على الأقل صادروا
سبائك ذهبية نقدية
وجوازات سفر تحمل أسماء مزيفة على ما
يبدو
يفترض استخدام evgeny Prague والشعر المستعار للتخفي ،
إنها عملية كاملة نوع من القمع
يبدو أنه يتعلق بأي شيء مع Wagner
أي شيء له علاقة بالتقدم المتطور
ولا يبشر بالخير للرجل الذي
ترأس Wagner بالطبع لا يزال يتجه ولكن
من قاد  هذا التمرد ضد
الكرملين ولذا سنرى ما سيحدث في
المستقبل ،
قال زعيم بيلاروسيا لوكاشينكو إنه لا يعرف ما
سيحدث لكنه قال إنه
لا يعتقد أن بوتين سيقتل براغ ،
قال إن هذا ليس شيئًا يعتقده
سيحدث ذلك ، لكن حقيقة أنه
أثار إمكانية
قتل التقدم لا تبشر بالخير لزعيم
فاغنر ، لذلك من الواضح أننا لم
نشهد بروغوزيانًا منذ ذلك
التمرد المسلح قبل 12 يومًا ، كان الجزء من
الصفقة التي تم الإعلان عنها هو أنه سيذهب
إلى بيلاروسيا لكن لوكاشينكو يقول إنه في
سان بطرسبرج ربما في موسكو ونحن
نرى أنه رجل حر يمكنه أن
يفعل ما يشاء وتحدثت معه
عبر الهاتف أمس على الرغم من أنهم
داهموا منازله وأخذوا
كل شيء  للخروج منه وهل تعلمون
إهانتهم بكل هذه الشعر المستعار وكل
شيء آخر يتجولون فيه
حول ما يجري هنا بيل
جيدًا أعتقد أولاً وقبل كل شيء
أنه ارتكب الخطيئة الأساسية المتمثلة في
جعل بوتين يبدو ضعيفًا.
هو نفسه لكونه ديكتاتورًا قويًا
وفراغوسيًا بشكل أساسي ، لقد
وضع حفرة للتو تلك
السمعة إلى النصف من خلال السير في
روستوف ، لم يقف أحد في طريقه ، لقد كانوا
يهتفون له لالتقاط صور سيلفي معه ، ثم
انتقل إلى فرناش ثم
اقتحم اثنين  لساعات في موسكو ، إنه نوع من
البطل الشعبي في روسيا ، وهو يجعل بوتين
يبدو وكأنه رجل ضعيف جدًا ، وما
يحدث الآن هو أن
الروس في حالة من
السكتة الدماغية بوتين خاصةً لأنه
تعرض لتحديه بالكامل.  لقد تم
تحدي نوع من صورة الرجل القوي ،
لذا من المؤكد أن أم الباغوزية لا تريد أن يتم
العثور عليها الآن يمكنني أن أتخيل أنه إذا
قاموا بكل هذه الأفلام
وفتحوا هذه القضايا الجنائية ضده
فسيحبون قتله إذا
تمكنوا من الحصول على  يدا بيد عليه ، ومن
المحتمل أنه ذهب إلى الأرض ، فهو
رجل خطير للغاية ولديه جيش كامل من
المرتزقة والأشخاص الموالين له نعم وماذا وما
نراه
الآن هو أنك تعتقد أنه ذهب إلى الأرض
وهو على قيد الحياة  في روسيا ،
من يدري ، أعني أن لديه العديد من
الطرق المختلفة التي تمكننا من حل الشعر المستعار الذي رأيناه في
جوازات السفر رأينا النقود
كانت هناك طائرة هليكوبتر
أم تعلمون في فناء منزله
أم أنه حصل على كل ما أعنيه أن هذا الرجل
لا يصدق من حيث  الأدوات التي
يملكها لك تتجنب أه من القبض عليه ، أعني
أنه القاتل الأكثر بدمًا باردًا
هناك ولذا لن يسمح
لنفسه فقط بتقييد يديه ونقله
بعيدًا إلى lupianca هذا
السجن العميق ، ليس الأمر ليس كذلك  حدث
ذلك وأنت تعرف أن الجميع يقول أنك تعرف
كم من الوقت يجب أن يعيش بشكل
جيد وأنت تعلم أنه حصل على كل هؤلاء القتلة
على كشوف رواتبه ، إلى متى يجب على هؤلاء
الرجال أن يعيش بوتين نفسه
مع هذا النوع من السيناريوهات.
يعني الجنرال هودجز أنه أمر
لا يصدق ومن المذهل ما
يظهرونه لنا بشكل صحيح هو أنك
تعلم أنه لا يوجد مكان يمكن العثور عليه فيه وهم
يصنفون منازلهم ويظهرون
تلك الشعر المستعار وتلك الأشياء ، ما الذي
يقوله لك هذا من
منظور عسكري آه يقول بوتين إن الصفقة صحيحة أو
حسنًا ، لقد قيل لنا أن الصفقة
المقترحة تذهب إلى بيلاروسيا ، تقول بيلاروسيا
إنه ليس هنا ، إنه في موسكو أو سان
بطرسبرج ، وهو من المخابرات العسكرية تمامًا ،
لذلك هناك ثلاثة أشياء آرون أولاً وقبل كل شيء
كيف يمكن لأي شخص  فكر بجدية في
المفاوضات مع روسيا ونتوقع
أنها ستلتزم بأي اتفاق أو أنها
ستكون شفافة بأي شكل من الأشكال ،
أعني السيرك الذي كنا نشاهده في
الأسبوعين الماضيين مأساويًا وأن
الناس يُقتلون ولكن هناك
الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يعتقدون أنه
يجب علينا دفع أوكرانيا للتفاوض مع
روسيا ،
فهؤلاء هم الذين تتفاوض معهم
ثانيًا نوع الأنشطة التي
رأيناها هنا خلال الأيام العديدة الماضية
بما في ذلك عندما ذبل الرئيس بوتين
عندما حوصر في الزاوية.
ذابل والتفت إلى لوكاشينكو
وأبرموا هذه الصفقة مع بروغوزيان الذي
من الواضح أنه لا يبدو كما
اعتقد الجميع أو كما اعتقدت
بأي حال من الأحوال ، لكن هذا ما فعله عندما
وضع في الزاوية ، لذا فقد أظهر
ضعفًا تمامًا كما قال بيل ولكن أيضًا
أخيرًا ، ليس هذا ما يحدث في جيش
واثق من أنه في طريقه
إلى النصر ، لذا فإن هذا يعكس حقًا
عدم اليقين وانعدام الثقة في
الحكومة والجيش ، لذلك
أريد أن ألعب أكثر من ذلك في
مؤتمر لوكاشينكو الصحفي حيث
أخذ كل هذه الأسئلة أه من
الصحفيين وفرصة ماثيو
قال إنه تحدث إلى باغوسيان بالأمس
ثم قال هذا بدون سبب عن
سلامة الباغوزيان ، دعني ألعب أن
ما سيحدث للباجوسيان جيدًا بعد ذلك
كل شيء يحدث في الحياة ولكن إذا كنت
تعتقد أن بوتين كذلك  خبيث
وانتقامي أنه سيقتل بروغوزيان
غدًا ، لا هذا لن يحدث على ما
يرام ، إنه يبرز من اللون
الأزرق ، لذلك هذا مهم ، ثم
يدعي أن هذا الادعاء لن يحدث ، أعني ماذا قرأت في هذا
البيان من لوكاشينكو
جيدًا أولاً  من بين كل هؤلاء الرجال
lukashenko Putin burgosian ، لا يمكنك
تصديق كلمة يقولون إنهم
يكذبون من بين أسنانهم إنهم يكذبون علانية
لذلك لا يمكنك تفسير أي شيء من هذا ،
وأعني أن ما سأقوله هو
ذلك أنت  تعرف أن هذا الرجل البروغوسي
نظم تمردًا مسلحًا لإخراج
بوتين ، فإن رد الفعل الطبيعي على ذلك هو قيام
بوتين بالقبض على جوشان
وإحضاره إلى الميدان الأحمر ووضع مقصلة
وقطع رأسه عن حقيقة أنه
لم يفعل ذلك أمرًا رائعًا.  حقيقة
أنهم سمحوا له بالذهاب إلى مكان ما سواء
كانت بيلاروسيا أو في مكان آخر ، أعني
بالأمس فقط أنهم كانوا بعد ذلك
عندما كان يقوم بغارة أمه ، قاموا هم
أو تمرده بتصنيف
مكتبه وصادروا 111 مليون
دولار من النقد
ثم  كما أفهمها بالأمس ،
أعادوا النقود ، فلا معنى لذلك ،
ومهما قالوه ، فهناك
الكثير من القصة التي لا نرى
على السطح
ما هو الرجل القوي عندما لم يعد
بهذه القوة مجرد رجل في  حصان
يحتاج إلى قميص اعتدنا عليه كثيرًا
مع صور فلاديمير بوتين هذه
كنوع من سوبرمان يتلاعب بالعالم
المعروف في لعبة عبقرية من
الشطرنج خماسي الأبعاد
ويصارع خصومه على السجادة
فكريا الآن العالم قادم
إلى  يتعايش بوتين مع مفهوم جديد تمامًا
يبدو أنه يلعب دور
المهرج هنا اليوم في معرض تجاري يصنع
رسمًا تخطيطيًا يعيش في واقع موازٍ
من مجرد انهيار عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
بينما فشل التمرد المسلح في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع من قبل
صديقه السابق المقرب.
أحد النجاح الكارثي الذي أدى إلى انفجار
فقاعة حصانة بوتين
[موسيقى]
لم يظهر رئيس الكرملين
علنًا لمدة يومين ونصف اليوم
فقط خارج الكرملين يوم الثلاثاء
لتقديم شكراً سرياليًا شكراً
للجيش الذي تراجع إلى الوراء و  دع فاجنر
يسير إلى موسكو ، أصبح بوتين الآن في مكان
لم يسبق له أن ذهب إليه من قبل للبحث عن
خونة في دائرته المقربة ، قيل إنه
عزل نفسه كثيرًا أثناء
الوباء ، مما أبقى الزوار على
مسافة ربما لم يعد قادرًا على
إيجاد طريقه للتراجع  الجدول إلى
الواقع ، انفجرت أيضًا فقاعة نخب موسكو اللطيفة
المتمثلة في الاستبداد المؤكد ،
إنها مكان تم جني الثروات فيه
من خلال الولاء الذي لا جدال فيه ، ولكن الآن
بعد غزو أوكرانيا يتصارع مع
الطائرات بدون طيار التي تهاجم الضواحي الفاخرة وحتى
الكرملين لم يكن من المفترض حدوث أي من هذا.
لا شيء من هذا هو ما باعه بوتين
لروسيا ولا يمكن الرد بسهولة على أي من هذا
من قبل رجل قوي لم يعد
يبدو أجنبيًا قويًا.